in this playlist we've been constructing
a monetary or banking system that
reasonably in a simplified form
approximates the system we're in so you
know we said okay we need a let's call
it a banking system
banking
system
and we went the fractional reserve route
we said oh you know what we'll take
deposits but we realize that you know
most of the deposits just sit there
people really don't use them so let's
re-lend out some of you know let's say
90 or 50 of the dot deposits some amount
and we have to keep some fraction aside
as reserves and that way we can use that
money to lend more but in the process we
create a multiplier effect and create
money so that's what we described a
fractional reserve system
so it was fractional reserve
fractional
reserve
and when we talk about reserves that
what we originally talked about reserves
was gold it was gold based we started
off with the farmers they had their gold
gold was the the unit of exchange from
primitive times it was the first agreed
upon medium and people kept with that
and then we eventually showed that in a
fractional reserve system when you have
this multiplier effect and you become
kind of an advanced western um
industrial economy to some degree the
gold might just sit in the central bank
vaults and just kind of provide this
this kind of confidence in the system
but it really it does nothing there just
provides a confidence and at some point
we showed i think it was in the last
video that you could actually just go
off the gold standard and you could
become you could go on to a non-hard
currency
or not backed
not backed by gold
and the point of that is really to get
to where we are today and to show that
it isn't
crazy you know there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of uh i guess you could
call them conspiracy theorists who think
that there was kind of a a negative
attempt behind going off of the gold
standard and that was somehow stealing
money and you know what i'm not 100 sure
that they're not wrong but i'm just
saying you know since then it's not like
we've had a heart you know wealth
destruction and that you know we've
turned into some type of um you know the
post-apocalyptic society with economic
growth has been pretty fast there's been
innovation productivity has increased so
at least as far as i can tell it seems
like you can have a reasonable economic
system that's not backed by gold that's
actually backed by the actual wealth
where the wealth is the productive
capacity of a country so not backed by
gold and that's where we got to in the
last video i think i struck a nerve a
little bit because i said you know the
gold really isn't fundamentally doing
something and that it really is just a a
medium of exchange
and and you know some people said oh how
can you say that gold is definitely
worth something you know there's no
reality in which gold cannot be worth
something gold controls other assets and
i think so it's good to
i think one think about what other
routes we could have taken down this
banking system evolution tree and then
also think about
i guess revisit the notion of gold
itself
so if we just think about let's revisit
gold first because i think that's what a
lot of people care about so there's two
things that i was drawing a difference
between and it's a philosophical
difference but i think it's an important
one it really helps
i guess
get a handle on things in the world so
there is money
money and then there is wealth
and this is tricky because you know the
end these are just definitions and
definitions take on different meetings
as time goes on i looked up wealth and
wikipedia and it gave the adam smith
definition and you know from the wealth
of nations and he talks about wealth as
uh the the land and i think it was the
land and labor that produce utility for
humans or something of that course so
you know it's essentially his definition
is wealth would be things like
land
it would be food
it would be shelter
it would be transportation
it would be
i don't know it would be entertainment
in on to some degree right that's that
provides some utility it makes us
happier entertainment
or it could be things that help produce
these things like factories or
who knows what else computers things
that help us produce all of these things
more efficiently
and if you if you stay in that mindset
money is not wealth money is just a
medium of exchange for wealth
medium
medium of exchange
and you know you could say money has
value the value of money it really is is
the oil or the lubrication of in the
economy without any form of money
you would have to be bartering and you
know if if i was a home builder and i
wanted to get bread i would have to
exchange a house for i don't know 10 000
loaves of bread which just is not
practical instead i can exchange it for
money and then later exchange that money
for bread
and within this money medium of exchange
context there's different types of money
right there's paper money
paper money
there's hard currency
etc and you know gold would gold would
fall under this context
and then there's a fundamental question
is is gold fundamentally fundamentally
intrinsically worth more than paper
money
and it i guess goes to just you know
what do you think is going to happen i
mean the the benefit or the negative of
gold you could or any a lot of hard
currencies is that it's scarce
it scares and by being scarce you know
it's it's kind of
it's it's not like you can just print
this stuff and it's there's always going
to be a set supply of it and so it's
it's you could say you know if someone
took a negative spin on it you doubt
scarcity would mean less flexible
less flexible
or if you took a positive spin on it you
could say it can't be manipulated
can't be manipulated
and both of these are probably true to
some degree right but that's just that's
what it is it's just a scarce unit of
exchange and so i'm not saying that gold
will one day
lose its ability to control some of
these things or be exchanged for some of
these things i'm just saying that money
or the unit exchange is fundamentally
different than these things that
actually provide utility i mean gold
does have some applications i mean maybe
you say it provides entertainment in the
form of jewelry maybe it does provide
some utility it you know can be used as
fillings or in some industrial or
electronic applications but primarily
it's a unit of exchange and as a unit of
exchange it helps just facilitate
the the transactions amongst these the
amongst wealth and helps the economy
kind of allocate resources efficiently
now paper money is not scarce right it's
controllable
and so you could take a negative or
positive spin on that right you could
say
it's
flexible that would be the positive spin
on it or you could say it's manipulated
it could be manipulated
and there are times in history
where
many governments just to kind of push
for populist
agendas or to
somehow try to defer problems maybe
until the next guy shows up
they did manipulate currencies and that
did lead to hyperinflation and
eventually the paper money becomes
worthless but then there's other
examples where the paper money for the
most part really does retain its value
so you know that's another thing to
think about
and so just going back to the the
question of whether gold will or will
not lose its value that's just really i
mean what is it going to lose its value
relative to and what would be the
catalyst for it so you know a lot of
people right now they'll say oh the
dollar there's going to be
hyperinflation because the fed is being
so proactive so i'm going to buy gold
and and and the only and they might be
right i'm not sure about that if i knew
about that i would go and speculate on
gold myself
but they they should just you know it
the main thing that in any type of
investment is to realize that you know
that is you're making a bet on what
human beings will do what the federal
government will do and you know just as
an example in real terms if you adjust
it for today's dollars gold in 1980 was
so real so gold in
this is in in inflation adjusted dollars
i think it was you know it was on the
order of twenty four hundred dollars
right so even today even with all of
this talk
i guess it's 2009 now even with all this
talk about hyperinflation the fed being
over overly aggressive and and and us
pumping up the into the money supply and
the fed's balance sheet expanding even
today gold in today's terms this is 2400
in today's terms is that i think it's at
840 or something
and back in 1980
back in 1980
a very reasonable person said my god we
have hyperinflation we just got through
these oil shocks inflation is going
through the roof inflation was already
much more rampant than it has been in
recent memory and you're like boy the
the dollar is going to be worthless
before you know before we know it i'm
just going to buy gold although you know
you don't know what it what should gold
be worth should it be worth 24 000
should it be worth
2 million dollars who knows or does it
you know does gold just go to infinity
in terms of dollars or does the dollar
just go to zero so someone could have
made a very reasonable argument back
then that they should you know get out
of their their bank account and convert
it all to gold and they wouldn't have
been able to predict that paul volcker
would show up in the early 80s and
and increase interest rates despite all
of the political pressure to maybe do
the opposite and
he got inflation under control and then
by was it by 19 by the late 90s i'll put
that here
by the late 90s
in today's terms gold was i think in you
know that the 200 ranger it might have
been even lower so we'll say
approximately 200
and even if that person said oh well you
know even the late nights i'm gonna i'm
gonna hold uh hold to my bet and keep
holding gold it would have taken if they
held it all the way to today they still
would have been better off in 1980
keeping their money in a bank account
that gets more interest than inflation
so if you just got three or four percent
on your bank account starting in 1980
you still would have been better off
than holding gold even though there was
a very credible argument for inflation
at that time so it's just a very very
hard thing to predict and with any of
these things that where you're really
just betting on the medium of exchange
it's very hard to price it it's very
hard to say what that unit of exchange
really is
so now people you know gold has run up
from the late 90s to 840 dollars it's
based on a lot of people thinking that
you know the dollar is going to lose its
value etcetera it's completely possible
we we might have an irresponsible
government i think inflation looks like
it's under control right now but who
knows what happens in a year or two
maybe all this liquidity starts to get a
multiplier effect and the dollar gets
debased and and gold jumps up
to
eight thousand dollars and those people
would have made a a great bet but maybe
inflation isn't the problem maybe it's
deflation and maybe people don't lose
faith in the currency maybe a paul
volcker show like a paul volcker like
character shows up and tackles inflation
and then gold goes back to two hundred
dollars
but the bottom line is here is that that
it's it's really hard to predict because
it's it's it's actually not generating
utility itself it's a measure of utility
but anyway i don't want to fixate on
that too much but it's an interesting
discussion
but anyway just going back to the
original thing there's other ways that
we could have gone down the evolutionary
path of banking systems i just wanted to
go over the path that we've gone
instead of a fractional reserve you
could have a full reserve system
you could have a full reserve
that's instead of you know me taking a
deposit and saying that you can demand
the deposit at any given point but still
lending ninety percent of it out that's
what i do in the fraction reserve i
would tell you you know what ninety
percent of your money you can't take it
out tomorrow it's going to be locked in
for six months it'd be like a cd and the
money that you want to have you know
tomorrow i'm just going to put it aside
you're not going to get any interest on
it and you might have to even pay me a
little bit of money to keep it you know
safe and to be able to access from an
atm that's completely fine you know
someone could argue that this is less
flexible
that would be the negative spin on it
less flexible but then the positive spin
on it it would be maybe it's less
less subject to manipulation
less manipulation or maybe there will be
kind of few less booms and busts right
maybe you know these bubbles won't form
i'm not so sure about that but it's i
think it's a reasonable argument and
then even within full reserve we could
have gone gold
or not gold
and once again that would have just been
a question about how much flexibility
you have even within full the the most
restrictive system would be a full
reserve system based on some type of
hard currency that can't be printed or
can't be controlled by humans to some
degree or you could have something that
is printed and then to some degree this
would be this could be manipulated a
little bit
and just like on the fractional reserve
you know fractional reserve backed by
gold a little less flexible but maybe
that's good a little less gameable as
well
anyway i just wanted to give you this
kind of overview of everything because i
think i
maybe struck some nerves in the last
time i didn't want to in any way insult
gold and i don't think that tomorrow
gold will be worthless i just wanted to
make it very clear that from a
philosophical point of view there is a
difference between gold and the things
that it can be exchanged for just as
there is a difference between money or
any kind of money paper money and the
things that it can be exchanged for and
in general i think gold does have a
special place
relative to any other hard currencies
relative to diamonds or
or nano tubes or anything else and
that's just because it has a history
right from if you beg from the beginning
of recorded history people used gold as
a medium exchange so it's almost
ingrained in our cultural dna and that's
what gives it this robustness as a as a
unit of exchange but other than that
it's really no different than diamonds
or carbon nanotubes or moon rocks anyway
i've used up all my time i'll see you in
the next video